[Musique]
l'hiver marque le retour inévitable des
virus gripaux selon les chiffre de santé
publique France la circulation des virus
est forte en île-de-fance et passe en
phase préépidémique avec 394 cas
d'infection respiratoirees aigu pour
100000 habitants la covid-19 est en
forte baisse par rapport à l'année
dernière mais reste tout de même
présente le ministère de la Santé
demande de conserver les gestes
barrières enfin l'agence observe une
baisse de la bronchiolite chez les
nouveau nés pour la 3è semaine
consécutive après un pic observé début
décembre le Centre Communal d'Action
Sociale des clés sous-bois dévoile son
programme d'animation senior pour la
nouvelle année de janvier à avril 2024
l'espace Jacqueline Oriol propose des
dîners spectacles des journées en forêt
des sorties au cinéma et aussi de la
danse et la nouveauté en 2024 des
initiations au langage des signes et au
théâtre d'improvisation les inscriptions
se feront à partir du 15 janvier 2024
par mail et par téléphone pour ce
nouveau weekend de vacances le trafic
routier sera fluide de manière générale
vendredi Bison Futé voie vert dans le
sens des départs et des retours mêmes
conditions pour samedi les autoroute à
13 et à1 sont au vert attention tout de
même si vous vous dirigez vers les
massifs montagneux de la région Auvergne
ronalpe ou des ralentissements sont à
prévoir et pour dimanche 31 décembre et
lundi 1er janvier pas de difficultés
particulière au niveau du
trafic